[Musique]
il ya plus de rapports des gens
directement avec la forêt de moins en
moins malheureusement comme d'autres à
la antoine aura consacré sa vie à la
fois ray
il
parmi tous les arbres qui l'a fait
tomber certains sont devenus des meubles
il espère sans trop y croire
des jours meilleurs pour une filière qui
était très présente dans les territoires
ruraux
[Musique]
on pouvait voir revenir ici ou là des
fabricants de chaises de tables non non
non non non sauf voilà sauf sur dd il ya
beaucoup de plus value sur des choses
très design très et tout ça on a le même
problème que dans tout le reste de
l'industrie
c'est les coups de main à deux qui sont
ce qu'elles sont ici et ou trop chers
les ébénistes français même nous ferait
connaissent l'exode économique
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien beau chaque fois que du bois
s'en va loin près de transformer il s'en
va il revient et c'est sûr si on devait
travailler de la même manière avec des
machines est tout autant le faire ici
quoi le prix de la sueur et du savoir
faire
le voilà le vrai prix du meuble
mais alors des armoires jetables
certains ne veulent pas baisser les bras
dans le haut doubs chez les lima on
fabrique des meubles depuis cinq
générations
laurent et même le dernier en france à
vendre et à bord et d'horloger je me
considérais comme un résistant
survivants un survivant résistance est
vrai que le métier a beaucoup évolué il
ya beaucoup maintenant elle est
confrontée à la mondialisation comme
beaucoup comme partout c'est vrai qu'on
a beaucoup de on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés mais ce qui nous tient nous
c'est vraiment la qualité de notre
travail est le fait qu' il n'y a pas
d'intermédiaire entre nous et le client
final
mais ce qui fait aussi le succès de cet
artisan ce sont ces tables parfaitement
adapter au xxième siècle et aux petits
logements et en particulier ce système
de police à bryant a mis au point qui
nous permet en fait de passer tout péter
talent alain table suffisamment
conséquente pour recevoir toute la
famille travail et du bois massif en
collant aux attentes des consommateurs
et en proposant des lignes très
contemporaines
ce n'est pas une issue de secours pour
les artisans plutôt même une voie
d'avenir
les grandes enseignes je sais pas s'il
vous revenir a dû à du local mais c'est
vrai qu'elles ont un petit peu de soucis
à se faire parce que comme dans
l'alimentation les gens reviennent un
petit peu au savoir faire spécifique sur
place etc
et c'est vrai qu'on a on a notre carte à
jouer à ce niveau là
dans notre région près de 3500 personnes
travaillent dans la fabrication de
meubles des petites entreprises
artisanales surtout qu'ils tentent de
maintenir le cap face aux géants du
secteur comme ikea dont la seule usine
française d'ailleurs ironie de
l'histoire se trouve en franche comté